bonsoir le château de villesavin eh bien
c'était une cabane de chantier vous la
voyez la cabane de chantier toute petite
cabane en fait c'était pas n'importe
quel cabane de chantier c'était la
cabane de chantier du gouverneur du
château de chambord en effet jean
lebreton habiter ici ils établissent et
les plans et la journée ils allaient au
château de chambord qui était à sept km
de là
alors aujourd'hui le château de
villesavin il appartient à la famille de
ce parent et cela depuis trois
générations
et cette famille a fait évoluer le
château en créant notamment le musée du
mariage et elle contient une collection
assez exceptionnel je vous propose de le
découvrir et on se retrouve juste après
avec le propriétaire du château près de
500 ans après sa construction le château
de villesavin n'a presque pas changé du
moins à l'extérieur à l'intérieur la
cabane de chantier de chambord ne
conserve que deux pièces telles qu'au
16e siècle notamment la cuisine un sol
qui est en très léger dévers et
légèrement incurvé en direction du petit
chat niveau à qui longe le mur là bas
juste en face de moi
le château a été construit entre 15 127
et 15 cents 37 pour le gouverneur des
travaux de chambord jean le breton qui
s'était lié d'amitié avec françois 1er
pendant les guerres d'italie
posté à de burst et sa résidence à il
avait une autre résidence à villandry
que vous connaissez certainement et donc
on l'a rapproché pas 200 jobs finalement
à chambord et voit la fonction de ce
château c2c d'accueillir ce tte cet
éminent personnage au sein de la
construction de chambord donc à une
dizaine de kilomètres aujourd'hui est un
petit peu plus de 7 à l'époque puisqu'il
existait à l'époque une allée qui
reliait directement les deux chattes
entre
quatre siècles et demi plus tard la
famille de spare achète le château le
cadeau d'un grand père pour sa petite
fille de 10 ans quand véronique et l'ars
de spare hérite du domaine en 1993 les
toitures fui l électricité manque il
décide de le restaurer de l'ouvrir au
public et de créer un musée du mariage
c'est avec cette collection de globes de
mariage acheté en bretagne que le musée
est né vous avez les petits miroirs
comme ça en forme de rectangle
ceci ils correspondent au nombre
d'années pendant lesquelles le couple
sait courtisé avant de se marier
ensuite vous avez les petits en forme de
losange comme ça qui correspond au
nombre d'enfants que la maman souhaitait
à ce couple là le globe de mariage il
n'existe plus aujourd'hui mais sa
fonction c'était de conserver la
couronne de fleur d'oranger que la
mariée portait le jour de son mariage et
donc ils agrémentent et tout autour tout
au long de leur vie de médaille
militaire de la dent de lait d'un enfant
et mèches de cheveux
ce musée unique en france compte 1500
pièces robe trousseau vaisselle retrace
l'histoire du mariage de 1850 à 1950
c'est super joli mais te revoir les
devoirs des robes d'époque qu'on n'a pas
toujours l'occasion
mon devoir c'est atypique ça change de
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui aussi et puis
enfin c'est à voir aussi de l'authentic
que pouvoir avoir la mémoire en fait de
l'histoire qui avait eu en plus dans
notre région la création du musée du
mariage il ya vingt ans a permis
d'augmenter le nombre d'entrées et de
financer une partie des restaurations
comme celle du pigeonnier l'an dernier
eh bien je suis avec le propriétaire du
château l'ars de spare bonjour bonjour
alors dites moi vous avez a hérité de ce
château la mort de votre maman est-ce
que c'est compliqué d'avoir un château
aujourd'hui
bah c'est pas très compliqué si on veut
dire ce que c'est un choix de vie
et ben voilà il faut trouver les
solutions pour pouvoir le gérer et
trouver surtout les finances et donc
pour les finances vous avez besoin des
visites c'est pour ça que j'avais créé
des musées notamment bas c'est à dire on
a le besoin évidemment des visiteurs qui
viennent visiter le château propre on
lit on a aussi une orangerie commis
depuis des décennies pour faire des
réceptions de mariage les salons
événementiel et autres là est tout autre
chose et aussi un côté agricole qui
permet pas de faire fonctionner la
boutique vous c'est une grosse
responsabilité ce château ses
responsabilités parce qu on a envie qui
est une continuité quand on a envie de
le sauver la responsabilité c'est qu'ils
ne s'écroulent pas été parfois non non
non non non évidemment des moments de
blues 1 quand comme ça va mal mais si on
a fait le choix d'y être
voilà on craque pas et puis on aime la
bâtisse donc ce serait difficile de 200
malgré tout vers autre chose
merci beaucoup merci monsieur de spar à
bien vous vous l'avez compris c'est
grâce aux visiteurs notamment que ce
genre de château peut être restaurée
entretenu on rappelle qu'il ya 890
château dans la région centre val de
loire et 120 qui sont ouverts au public
voilà ils sont ouverts tout l'été des
animations des musées pas c'est à vous
de jouer nous on voulait c'est la forme
cette série sur les châteaux privés en
centre val de loire
bonne soirée